hospitals across the country say they
are overwhelmed by a triple democ by now
we know what that means covid-19 the flu
and of course RSV nearly 80 percent of
hospital beds are in use Nationwide so
according to the CDC 45 states have high
or very high levels of respiratory virus
Tennessee is one of the hardest hit
Janet shamley and went to a children's
hospital in Memphis to see what doctors
and nurses on the front lines there have
to face
to your heart emergency room nurse Grace
Peavy is checking out Isabella white her
mom says the three-year-old has been
sick all night if she's not there enough
when she's done there's a room full of
feverish children and fearful parents 2
6 52 still waiting to be seen I'm trying
to make sure she's not dehydrated at Le
Bonner Children's Hospital in Memphis
this is not an unusual day how many
times is that waiting room full every
day it's the story of pediatric
hospitals Nationwide how does this
compare to what you saw during covid
well this really is the Pediatric
experience of covet the volumes of
patients that the adult Hospital saw
during coven that's what we're
experiencing now in the neonatal
Intensive Care Unit
eight-week-old Maverick King has spent
four of them here battling RSV it's
definitely not how I thought we'd spend
our first two months or his first
Thanksgiving and it's so close to
Christmas is he okay yeah he's just
upset
his mom Brittany tells me at least he's
off the Venom I don't think there's any
words to sit there and watch your
newborn baby have to be intubated to
breathe upstairs in the Pediatric
Intensive Care Unit
seven-year-old Valeria garuno had a
life-threatening case of the flu so she
was very serious yes she was
she was coming to an end
yeah it was hard
but she is here
supplies are sometimes short and
Staffing is not at 100 percent but
workers are taking extra shifts we can
in on being back home for Christmas yes
a heavy toll on caretakers and hospitals
amid a surge of sickness for CBS
mornings I'm Janet shamlian in Memphis
it's so hard to see the children sick
especially when they can't talk like the
little baby you can tell that cry is
very different than how they normally
cry yeah yeah and it's unfortunate
because the shelves are empty that's
right his parents are struggling to find
what they need for their kids and it's
the time of the year where you want kids
to be running around happy you know rosy
cheeks red nose and not in the hospital
yeah it's tough